[Music]
first it's a little bit about myself
I've been working in the cloud industry
for a while now I started my career at
PayPal moved on to Amazon got to see
kind of the differences and how they
built apps which was really interesting
but I really wanted the startup
experience that everybody comes to
Silicon Valley for and I stumbled upon
this crazy little company called Heroku
that was doing well the time was called
platform as the sir as a service for
Ruby apps and I had built a rails app
for a failed startup and so is this
weird person who could make spreadsheets
code in Ruby and maybe think about what
products people should build so I became
a product manager and the first dozen or
so people at Heroku had a great run
there it was a ton of fun managed and
started the Heroku Postgres product
which maybe some of you have used and
for a while PM to the main Heroku
product then I left there did a couple
things spend a couple years at docker
and then I found my way over to Google
Cloud and so now we're so I'm peeing the
App Engine product which is actually
Google clouds oldest product it predates
Google cloud and it's it kind of had
been the janky old product in the
portfolio but in the last couple of
years we've been reinvesting in it and
now it's the really cool vintage product
in the Google portfolio so I hope you
folks will be excited about it and give
it a try so you can post your questions
on Dory and I'll take a look at them at
the end I think you can link to it from
the next app I don't know if not you can
use this ugly URL here okay so what
we're going to cover today first I'm
going to talk about just where your
options for Rubio and Google cloud then
I'm going to show you a basic app
basically I this is an app Heroku circa
2013 or so rails Postgres and Redis
running on like in a single location
then we're gonna do something that
frankly I've always wanted to do which
is build a app that spans multiple
continents and geo routes to them based
on where you are and is resilient to an
entire continent going down its ICBM
proof as I like to say okay so first of
all if you take one thing away from this
it's this Ruby is now on App Engine in a
really big way we announced that
yesterday in the big mega blog post
about server lists we got a whole
paragraph mention it is in alpha I can
say it has a couple of rough edges but
it's actually pretty good for an alpha
product I've been really banging on it
hard and it it works which is great so I
will show a URL at the end for how you
folks can use it it is a private alpha
but all you have to do is join a Google
group and it'll magically work for you
okay so let's talk about your Ruby
options on Google cloud before there was
basically only one option which is app
engine flex and for those of you who
might not be familiar with App Engine
there's basically two flavors two
environments there's flex and standard
and it's kind of environments a bit of a
misnomer
they're basically completely different
products completely different code bases
different user interfaces app engine
flex has used to be called managed
virtual machines and that's what it is
it's basically like a service like
experience on virtual machines so
scaling it out you know takes like 10
minutes because you got to wait for the
virtual machine to load deploys take a
while you know an abstract some things
away but it's not really service because
there's servers there so you the the
choices were kind of barren but now oh
my gosh
we still have that bench in flex but now
we've got App Engine standard a
second-generation runtime we've got
cloud run which is just announced you
can just create a container it can't
have Ruby in it cloud run doesn't care
what's in the container and it works or
you can do cloud on a gke where you take
that container and run it on your own
private gke cluster so lots of choices
they all work pretty well it's a lot of
fun now I want to go
okay here we go so again take a quick
picture of this if you want to try it
this is a super ugly URL App Engine -
standard-issue b25 - alpha Google group
you'll go to the Google Groups login
with your Google account the same want
to use on Google Cloud join the group
it's set to just Auto accept anybody who
joins and that puts you into the Alpha
and there will be a link there to Doc's
on how you use it but we'll be showing
you that today it's pretty
straightforward
here's that dory link again if anybody
has questions you can also ask questions
live but this is you know if you're shy
and don't want to get up and talk you
can just put it in on your app and do a
question there alright so I want to show
you simple Ruby app but actually let's
take a detour and talk about why Ruby
I'm actually curious like most people
here at rubyists if you just want to
shout out like why why do you program in
Ruby anybody it's easy I think it's
super easy I I like to I pride myself on
being a really bad programmer and Ruby
is a language that makes a lot of sense
to me anyone else why Ruby what's that
rails yes rails is awesome it's not cool
it is super duck not cool right now but
I think it is awesome if you want to
build a web app that's backed by a
database it's it's such a no-brainer you
can create a rails app in a second you
could fire up a scaffold
basically with a couple of commands you
could have a working app and I'm
actually giving a talk in about an hour
talking about sort of productivity with
serverless
and to me rails and server let's go
hand-in-hand you can build an app in
like under an hour and you can deploy it
in a couple minutes and you can have you
know you can actually test out to see if
it's something useful which is great I
also think Ruby is great and rails too
for expressing business logic like
you're the you know having a model you
can have an invoice model invoice doc
create creates a new invoice I've always
taught send you you can create this code
that is very easy to read very business
friendly and I think it's one of the
best ways to model business logic out
there
and it turns out most apps have that
sort of logic in it all right
so let's talk about a simple Ruby app
we're gonna use these things App Engine
cloud sequel cloud memory store and VPC
connector so let me let me tell you
about what's changed in the in the
Google cloud world on why this is
relevant the Genki old App Engine of a
couple years ago it was this all-in-one
product
it came with datastore it came with a
special flavor of memcache that was
memcache G for Google it was different
from regular memcache and those services
worked really well they worked perfectly
out of the box but if you want to use
something else tough luck you couldn't
you couldn't even get direct network
access you had to use a special API
called URL fetch you wanted a different
library you couldn't use it you can only
get the libraries that were on there and
the the language runtimes themselves
weren't even the open source ones they
were these special Forks of the
languages that Google maintained so in
other words it was super proprietary but
last year we released something called
second generation runtimes which is kind
of what people expect these days it's a
fully open source language runtime has
direct network access obviously and so
that was a big step forward but the Ruby
second duration runtimes run on an
entirely different cluster from the rest
of Google Cloud and they weren't able to
talk to a lot of the Google cloud
services so also yesterday we released
something called VPC connectors and this
kind of completes the picture for using
sec app app engine second gen runtimes
and Ruby they let you connect to any VM
or any service built on VMs which is
like cloud sequel or Redis that's
running in Google Cloud so now you can
sort of use all the parts of Google
cloud along with your App Engine app and
and that's another big takeaway that you
should get is that you Google Cloud has
all these fun toys AI artificial
intelligence api's Redis memcache
spanner all these cool things and
with App Engine you can actually use
them which is great all right so it's
pretty easy this is like the bare-bones
set up in your gem file or you know
wherever you're specifying your ruby gem
you want to do sort of two five three or
greater that it's we're currently
running Ruby two five three and it's
going to be 255 shortly maybe we'll go
to two six we'll see App Engine has
something called an app demo that's
where you configure it and tell it what
it is you're doing you need to tell it
you're using the Ruby runtime you tell
it an instance class there's f1 f2 and
f4 the f1 is 128 megabytes of RAM and it
turns out that it's not enough RAM to
run even most basic ruby apps so you
need to do an F - but I've got really
good news and you guys are some of the
gonna be so the first to hear it later
this quarter we're gonna be doubling the
memory on all the second gen instances
so you go to use an f1 for the same
price as the f2 that F 1 will be 256
Meg's which is enough for a basic Ruby
app and finally you set something called
an entry point and this is just the
command that gets run you basically it
could be your rail server command or it
can be you know a puma command directly
or whatever you want and then on the CLI
you just type in g-cloud app deploy
that's assuming you've got the g-cloud
client if you don't just install it and
boom it should work all right so that
that would get you like just like a
hello world app but hello world doesn't
really get you very far so you'll
probably almost all apps we talked about
you know rails rails has great rails
usually once a relational database and
it really likes really likes Postgres
that's my favorite so to set this up
just click into the cloud sequel part of
the Google console and you're gonna fill
out this form here you give it some name
generate a password oh I have all those
oh okay I didn't step through this okay
so yeah you'll give it a you just click
that generate password button and copy
that pick a region you can choose to run
it in the US west central or east
Europe we got lotsa lots of regions it's
one of the really cool things about
Google cloud and really important and
this is actually a little caveat I ran
into enable a public IP otherwise it it
doesn't seem to work in theory you
should be able to have a private IP and
connect via the VPC connect but once we
get that working we'll document that
properly this is still alpha okay then
one of the cool things you can do in
that app EML this is an app engine
specific thing is you can set
environment variables so just set your
that password you generated just stick
it in there tell it what your user is
and tell it what the host is that hosts
after after this screen after you
actually click the create it'll give you
this host you just pull out the called
sequel - there's this sort of special
UNIX socket that gets created on App
Engine to connect to your cloud sequel
instances and so that's actually what
it's doing and then in your rails app in
your databases dot yeah mo you just
reference those environment variables
for setting up your database all right
now well I like I talked about before
creating a VPC connector so by default
when you create a project in Google
Cloud you get a virtual private cloud
that has you know all the where that's
we stick VMs that are shielded from the
big bad dangerous internet so it's
really easy you just cook into here
you're gonna have to enable VPC access
for some reason i don't get like most of
the products on google cloud don't work
by default you have to first enable the
api then you can use them I don't know
why that is I'm sure there's a good
reason for it
but it makes for awkwardness and getting
started okay then you're gonna click
into surplus BBC access and just click
create a connector boom you tell it
which network you get this default one
by default you're gonna need to type in
an IP range with a dash 28 sitter range
just use the default one that's in that
little help text there and there you go
now you're gonna create a Redis instance
so again you just click on to memory
store
create it give it a name pick the region
pick you probably at the region to be
the same one that you picked for App
Engine because you want to be a nice
fast internet access and that is
basically you want you could choose
there's basic and standard tiers the
standard tiers have failed over but we
don't need that for our demo and then
we're gonna configure the app to use
Redis that's all you stick that in your
production you know config tell it to
use that and you see we're using that
Redis URL which I had back here and so
back in that a p.m. we also see that VP
see access connector you have to put
that in to make the V PC work and then
you stick in that Redis URL at the very
bottom there and that's the address of
the of the reticence since you just
created and then it will all work
alright so I'm not gonna actually go
through all that live because it's you
know takes like 15 minutes but we can
just pull up a working app prove that
it's working ok could I get D there we
go cool so I created this app I'll pull
it up here let's make this not terribly
small
so here's this app it's just a simple
app with two models and let's so here's
that a PM Ovid that I was showing you
before this is all the live stuff I
guess as my credentials in it off to
destroy this database now otherwise
heaven forbid you could put data in
there so that's the basic app and boom
it is running right here you can see you
get this little appspot.com domain this
is an app it tracks watches because I've
been collecting watches lately and it's
kind of a fun thing to put in a database
and you can put in a URL and it works
and that is a rails app running on App
Engine for some reason it's been super
slow in the leo you can see it's loading
up right now I have no idea why that is
but again it's alpha so it's slow and
man that is really painful really
painful all right well it's not supposed
to work that way but the demo gods are
not looking favorably on us all right so
let's switch back into the presentation
okay again put some questions in dory
all right now let's get to the fun part
so let's look at a world-spanning ruby
app now I think when at least for me
when we when I first got interested
cloud computing this is kind of what I
wanted I wanted a cloud that spanned the
world and I've talked to lots of
customers of Heroku and Google Cloud and
docker and there's like I'd say like one
out of five maybe one out of two times
they were like when you they say well
can you run it in different places yes
can I run in all those places at once
no it's really it's something that
that's really hard to do but it's kind
of something that people wants right you
know it's it's the cloud it's not
located anywhere right it's just kind of
ephemeral see one you want a cloud that
covers the world but really you end up
getting this it's like yeah you can put
wherever you want and sense
east-west we've got all of them pick one
alright so yeah it's great it's still
super awesome to not have to manage all
these things I have to go down to the
data center but it's not that kind of
cloud of our dreams but it's actually
possible to build so let's build it so
these are this we're going to use for
this I'm gonna use the new cloud on gke
product that got launched yesterday it
is super cool if you are
if you are running kubernetes in your
organization but want to have a server
list experience it is a smoking-hot
product you should probably have like
two sprays someone in your company
that's like the kubernetes operator
maybe two people but then you put cloud
run on top of it and you don't need to
worry about the kubernetes stuff will
also use spanner so one of the hardest
parts about creating an app in multiple
locations is the data it's really easy
to just run something that returns hello
world and that's it you can run that in
Molden places but who cares
almost all apps need data and data is
heavy and so it doesn't like to move
around a lot but we've got this really
cool technology called spanner and we'll
back it with that you use cloud memory
Redis the same way that we did in the
other app and again that VPC connector
and then to wrap it all together we'll
use cloud fare to do the geo routing
well there was a really cool map of the
world there but that's not loading for
some reason so imagine there's a app
here there's a map here we're gonna run
this in US central one which is in Iowa
and UAE US which is in Belgium and in
Asia it's going to one app three
continents load-balanced so it'll go to
whichever continent you are closest to
and it'll have automatic failover here's
the architecture so on the front like I
said the hard parts about this are the
load balancing and the data doing the
apps actually pretty easy so we'll use
cloud fare for a Geo load balancer
currently the Google cloud load balancer
does not work well with cloud run
hopefully in the next by the end of the
year that will not be the case
so you could just keep it all in the
Google cloud but frankly it doesn't
matter CloudFlare is a great product it
worked it was super it was actually one
of the easier parts of this whole demo
to set up I had never done I'd never
used this part of CloudFlare before but
it took me under an hour from like
learning on how to set it up it'll geo
balance to the code running in any one
of these three regions when I made this
slide I was going to try to use App
Engine but it turns out cloud run worked
a little bit better the reason for that
by the way is you can only have one App
Engine app for Google Cloud project so
that makes it hard to have an app
running in three places you can create
multiple projects but then those apps
can't all connect to the same spanner
instance because the apps connect to the
spanner instance in their project
projects are these kind of fenced
balance in Google cloud then we'll have
a cache layer and then the the spanner
database and back so here's some caveats
there's no active record support for
spanner if you google it you will find a
gem it hasn't had an update in two years
so it's not based the latest Ruby
version it's not based on the raised
rails version it does actually work on
the versions that it talks about but it
was a proof of concept it was built by
someone who used to work at Google and
it did work as a proof of concept the
Ruby team at Google is hoping to build
an active record adapter for spanner
later this year that means that
hopefully next year it'll exist I would
love it if if that does exist doing this
will become exceedingly simple because
without active record rails kind of
isn't very friendly to use caveat number
two is you're gonna need to use the
Google Cloud client library and it does
not support process forking you you
maybe you've delved into this but most
modern servers they'll fork the process
and get better concurrency that will
just break the the G RPC library which
the cloud clients based on
and so you just need to set your app to
not fork you know what if you're using
Puma there's like a simple flag to do
that
and third caveat is oh my god it is
expensive like this is not for the faint
of heart you know this is really cool
and it's almost kind of cool how
expensive it is how expensive is it it's
about a Tesla Model 3 per month and
that's if you use the barest bone
configuration right so like like the
barest bone spanner configuration that
runs on three continents is about 27,000
dollars per month
yeah it's silly it's silly expensive the
good news is like if you're a really big
company that that's a spanner instance
you can have up to a hundred databases
on an instance so each database is
actually to cost you about 270 bucks a
month which is super reasonable so if
you're or if you work for a big company
and they decide to use spanner for a
bunch of things it starts to become
pretty cost effective or if you're at
really big scale right I mean if you're
running like the next super hot startup
twenty seven thousand dollars a month to
have like global reach is pretty
reasonable
there's also a whole gke cluster each
cluster in each continent has like 45
gigs of ram and three nodes and costs
like another several thousand dollars a
month so it's pretty pricey but it's
cool you can do it okay so how do you do
it first you have to create a spanner
client I just created a little
initializer and this is straight out of
the spanner docks and you can see the
very end there the little dollar sign
that makes it a global and she just
access this from anywhere in your rails
app then you need to populate it the
cool thing about spanner is it's plain
vanilla sequel so this is just some
plain sequel I just created it and
pasted it in on the spanner console and
created my table I'm the the the
operators just a very simple like posts
app web that has messages and like I
said before there's no active record
support fortunately there's this thing
in rails now called act
model which is a lot of active record
without the database but you just need
to recreate some of the methods that
active record would otherwise give you
so what's going on here
I when I was more ambitious there was an
image uploaded on this app it didn't
quite work we have the active model in
this post class we also have a few other
things that like these URL helpers that
just make things work you unlike if an
active record app can educate this
attribute accessor these are just the
various attributes there's that's in the
database it lets you access them
and you can do validation and that's the
basics of creating a model then we just
need to recreate some of the methods
active record gives you here's a simple
finder you pass it an ID then it just
executes this sequel where you find a
post and return the first one there
should only be one but better safe than
sorry so that would be you know post out
find then once you have one if you want
to save it boom you just do a
transaction and insert the stuff into
the database I'm just passing in
whatever got set on that model and you
could do a like find all where you just
do a select star and you know limit it
to you don't know if you have a lot of
stuff you don't want too many of them so
this is recreating what the methods that
active record would give you by default
again if we make a active record spanner
adapter you won't need to do this it'll
be really easy alright
then setting up CloudFlare so glad for
you just out of sight you create these
things called pods pods are nominally
collections of servers but since with
server lists you are getting a
collection of servers you basically just
map each of these to one of your
deployed instances and then you create a
load balancer and the load balancer is
just saying load balance between these
pods and you can see the very top there
you give it a URL in order for Klaus
from the work you need to be doing your
DNS and it'll automatically create all
the DNS magic you can also create some
health checks here just make sure it's
working
okay so let's switch into demo mode
again wake up my computer now the demo
gods were not friendly to me and for
some reason the so here's the app and
maybe my Internet's not even working oh
I see wrong URL
boom alright so it says this app is
being served from the EU so the demo
gods were not friendly to me but it
actually helped demonstrate kind of some
of the power of this for some reason I
could not get the US version of this app
working something got worked in the
configuration but guess what the
CloudFlare geo routing also does
failover so it's it's routing us to the
EU version of the app and that's
basically just pulling out a config var
that lets you know where it's being
served from that little message at the
top so what this looks like in Google
Cloud Oh too big so you go into Google
Cloud console and you tap on cloud run
and basically you just create a service
actually let's deploy
let's show a full deploy here I'm gonna
go to my command line and here's the
directory so here's this hi world app I
need to switch to the project
so can we talk about those projects this
app has its own project alright so now
I'm going to use that project and now
I'm going to do a build let's just see
just pulled out of my command history
here all right so
G cloud build submit and you give the
tag so with this too we have this other
product called
cloud build and it takes a takes a
docker file and builds it for you so I
just told it to build that and tag it
with this GC r dot io is our container
registry and it's going to fetch this
thing and pull it all up into the cloud
you can also do the build locally with
docker and then just push it up there it
actually will work faster if you build
locally because right now cloud build
does not cache your layers in docker see
this it goes through all the regular
build stuff there's just plain vanilla
docker nothing special about this that's
the power of cloud run once it's built I
can create a service and I just go into
cloud run here let's start from the
beginning I just go into cloud run click
create service pick my container image
there we go give it a name
now when you pick a region this is cloud
run not on gke right now it's only
available new essential but then these
are my gke clusters that I set up before
I just pick which one I want to deploy
to Asia and we said we allow it to
connect to the internet optional
settings you can pick how much memory
each instance of this app gets you can
add any config VAR variables you want
here so I on this app I've got a region
click create and it's going to deploy
and that's all it takes to deploy
something to cloud run and then over
here just to show you what's happening
in cloud flare we've got this load
balancer that visible so in cloud flare
there's this little traffic tab here and
you set up a load balancer I've got this
one it's hosting the demo sub domain and
you can see it's got two pools active
here's that u.s. pool that wasn't
working I just turned it off because it
was having problems but now it just
routes to my European pool and my Asia
pool if we take a look at one of those
this is just the default IP address that
I get on caught on gke I just stuck that
in there straight out of the console
I'll show you that
here's that European version of the app
there's that and I basically just copy
and pasted that into here and here we
are have the working hello world app
super small wrong way
hello cloud next 2019
boom and there it is hello called that's
our second second time I made that
message okay it works cool being stored
from the EU because the US is down right
now
that's a world-spanning ruby app hope we
go back to my slides Thank You
world-spanning ruby app you saw it here
first there's nothing special about Ruby
you could do this with really any docker
container node bash whatever you want
just needs to listen on port 80 alright
wrapping up so I think one of the points
of this talk is Google cloud has a lot
of cool building blocks
there's spanner there's machine learning
api's there's all these cool things and
what's really fun is in just a couple
days or a couple hours depending on how
good you are
it took me a couple days because I'm a
really bad programmer you can snap them
together and create something really
powerful a second take away Ruby is on
the cloud in a big way so on all those
services so if you've been waiting to
use Google cloud but we're deterred by
the lack of Ruby support it is there now
and again to try it right now there is
the URL just join that Google group and
you can use it today
I would love feedback just email me
directly Sol do at Google
[Music]